foreign
let's go out to uh Denise in Raleigh
what's up Denise
hey Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call today of course how we doing
pretty good how are you I mean it'd be
hard-pressed to be better but that's
cool what's up
a little bit of a what would you do or
what should I do kind of question for
you
um I have been in martial arts for
probably about 12 years now with a
particular uh black belt at a gym for
the past six I found out recently that
he was investigated for sex acts with a
minor
um the police department involved felt
that they had enough to make a case but
the parents opted not to press charges
to prevent a public hearing that
involves their daughter
um I was not aware of it when it
happened this all happened I guess a
year ago but I found out recently I
teach a women's self-defense course at
this gym
and I don't know if I can continue doing
that now that I know things that I can't
unknow about this individual who owns
and owns this place
have you talked to him directly
I am in a little bit
little bit of the go I stumbled across
them on social media and they left over
this issue
I then I didn't want to get into a well
he said this about you so I left kind of
situation I verified it with the chief
of police in our our cities like the
local police department that did the
investigation
and they also said that he you know the
police chief said this is being told in
confidence because the case was closed
without charges but yes it's true
um so I can't go to him and say this you
know people who aren't supposed to be
saying this about you told this to me
but I did tell him that I was told by
people who work in local law enforcement
recently that
um their personal opinion was that women
were not safe at this particular gym
which is true if they did say that and
it was a personal opinion not a
professional opinion and that until I
understood why they would say that about
our gym I was not going to continue
teaching the women's class or
encouraging women to train there what
was his response by the way
hell yeah good for you I'm proud of you
for that that's that was a hard
conversation wasn't it it was yeah I
kind of wanted to throw up after I got
off the phone well I'm proud of you good
for you how was that conversation
received
uh he went into some other things I
guess he had had an affair with a
different woman at some other point in
his life and said that he thought that
was why they said that about him and if
he never presumed to be a perfect person
and I was like no we all know that about
you we know you're not a perfect person
but you and your wife were separated and
then you ended up getting back together
and moving on whatever this is something
completely different
and it's local like it's recent and he
was like oh I don't know what that's
about yeah I'd walk away I'd walk away
he was fudged on it yeah I'd walk away
and
the gym I was a part of I was not a part
of it for 12 years I was a part of it
gosh several years I've only been at
this one for six but yeah not six long
enough but I'm telling you I understand
that that's your I'm asking you to leave
your family
yeah like it's it's where you spend your
time it's where you've had Great
accomplishments it's where you've
overcome failure it's already been hurt
and people rally around you
it's a tall order to walk away
but I am not going to put my my name
next to somebody that is a knowing
sexual predator especially with children
us just with a period at the end and I
was going to say especially if I'm
inviting women into this space taking
their money that's going to pay for this
dude's rent I know right yeah I can't I
mean I couldn't get in good conscience
do that but I couldn't I couldn't take
15 men and bring them in there and make
that guy one penny richer with
um
on yeah I I'd walk away and I hate it
there's no way to guarantee that he
wouldn't he wouldn't do it again and and
it was with a young girl at the gym too
so it just made it all more all the more
kind of in my face is like wow I can't I
can't do this because again with one of
the women that you invite here yeah and
you you know as well as I do
I hope this doesn't sound bad to the
audience who hasn't been a part of these
gyms but there's there's never layers I
mean there's always layers there's never
levels to sexual assault but I
particularly find when martial arts
instructors are groomers
um and it's rare so don't you think this
is a thing like I am wait till my
daughter goes and does martial arts so
it's not that at all but there is a
power hierarchy there and a power
Dynamic and a respect Dynamic that's
such an integral part of the class that
doesn't exist in so many other social
spaces
that the violation is so deep and
egregious
yeah
you know what I mean I walked away from
the police chief's conversation I was
I was that's exactly what he did yeah
yeah
um I mean if you're my sister I would
tell you
to never walk back in that gym again
okay I'm glad to hear you say that
because I told him I was at least taking
a break and possibly never coming back
and he texted me today asking if I could
cover the next two weeks of women's
classes of course he did geez Louise I
thought we had a conversation about this
yeah he doesn't give a crap what you
think
um
you're just one of the women that makes
him money I I he here's the here's I
want to I'm going to walk you through
how I thought through this okay
sure because I also have been doing
sexual assault investigations for most
of my career and okay I understand there
is two sides to every story okay
the fact that you have worked with him
side by side for six years
you have had a
um Mentor mentee relationship
you've been through him through a
marriage breakup you now are an employee
and he didn't have the
honor and dignity of either telling you
yeah I really screwed up or
hey this story is going out there about
me and it's not true and here's what
happened
instead instead he said I think you're
stupid and I'm just gonna play dumb
so if he had called you and said Hey
listen this story is going on about me
that I hooked up with a minor it is not
true it's just simply not
um you're you're in North Carolina the
consent age is insanely low there like
yeah like this is what this is It's it
that's I I won't respect what he did
manipulated the consent age yeah
intentionally he had known the girl
since she was 14 and he waited until she
was 16. yeah I mean yeah so in his mind
I didn't commit a crime I did exactly
what the law said and
um cool that
what I was looking for there is his
Integrity to have a conversation with
you he didn't do that
and so yeah and by the way I don't care
what that law is I'm not gonna hang out
with grown men who sleep with 16 year
olds I'm just not I don't want those
people in my life I'm not going to learn
from those people I'm not gonna go have
drinks with those people
I don't care what the law is that's
disgusting it's disturbing
can I ask a
secondary question sure
adds a little bit
of alcohol how to navigate the second
part of this which is
uh my career is that I teach horseback
riding lessons and his daughter has
taken lessons from me for the past six
years ever since I we met each other at
the gym and he was like oh you do horses
my kids love sources can she ride with
you
and just wondering how to navigate that
moving forward because he's a grown man
he gets to make his choices
pull his daughter out then he chooses to
pull his daughter out well that's just
it he's not and I I I don't think that
she deserves to have her life blown up
over and she can't help that he's a
dirtbags so yeah
and if as long as it's not some sort of
you don't see any kind of red flag with
discontinuing that part
I was going to just continue the speech
I mean her kid out here that's up to you
unless you unless you simply don't want
this being in your presence
well he's not usually the one who drops
her off and picks her up it's usually
the mom yeah that's up to you I mean
that's that's I wouldn't sleep over
there that's up to you
um your relationship in that scenario is
with the kid right if he was coming out
for horseback riding lessons I might say
I probably don't want you out here
anymore
yeah but this one's a little bit
different yeah
um and I'll say this every case is
different every case has twists and
turns my guess is given the North
Carolina consent age and I think is it
yeah 16. God that's insane it's insane
um
I mean golly dude that just blows my
mind I need to take a second
um
if the consent age is is
no I forgot him I was going to say
don't be sorry that's on me I just can't
I can't wrap my head around the fact
that it's 16.
um yeah I lost it so there you go that's
how good I am at this job
amazing you're great I enjoy listening
to you and that was one of the reasons
why I wanted to get your advice on this
because it's been it's been a lot
your values always are gonna cost you
something
oh man isn't that the truth yeah yeah
and
um walking away is gonna cost you
professionally it's gonna cost you
financially it's he may blackball you at
another gym it's just gonna cost you
yeah and I don't want to hang out with
dudes who groom 14 year olds until they
become 16 year olds
do you think I have any kind of
obligation to try to explain this to any
of the women
I've been asked to keep some of it in
confidence by I wouldn't participate in
that
um I have a personal philosophy I don't
answer questions unless directly asked
um and in this situation I'd probably
say I've chosen to not be around him
okay and let that be oh I remember what
I was going to say
um my guess is the consent age was 16.
and the police officers told his family
or her family
we can drag through this whole thing and
at the end of the day we think he's
gonna walk
you know at least you've indicated that
they thought they had enough to put him
in jail and get him on a sex offender
list but they often they I think they
just didn't want the police she said
they the parents didn't want the the
trauma of a public hearing for their
daughter
I get that
but maybe he was going to walk anyway
I only know what I'm being told they may
man
they they think they're avoiding trauma
by keeping this whole thing quiet and I
can tell you
there will come a day when this little
girl looks at Mom and Dad and says why
didn't you protect me from that guy why
is he still out there
that's a mess I'm sorry Denise thank you
so much for thinking through this with
me and being brave and for everybody
listening I hope you can hear I tried to
paint a picture here here's here's why I
would make the decision the way I made
it I am not a fan of grenade throwing I
am a fan of getting direct information
and when something happens like this I'm
a fan of calling somebody very directly
and asking some very poignant questions
and how they respond and how they treat
me with dignity respect how they tell
the truth how they avoid it whatever
that plays a huge role in whether I'm
going to ride with you to the end of
this thing or I'm going to say okay but
your behavior is telling me you don't
want me here because you're lying to me
you're not being honest I'm going to
walk away
and um
remember at the end of the day a lie
at its core is one person looking to
another and saying
I think you're stupider than me
and I think I can withhold what actually
happened I can withhold truth you will
never know
I'm just not into people calling me
stupid it happens a lot in this job but
I don't love it
That's it man thank you so much for the
call Denise let me know how it all goes
we'll be we'll be rooting for you